members officers and uh members of the
public who may well be watching us as we
are being live streamed
um i think um once again members are
aware how
this works um i think we should be used
to it by now
but i am going to for the most part call
out
your names to see whether you're here
uh that is the members of the actual
planning committee so i i do know there
are other people
uh wish to speak and so forth so if i
may start with
uh say hey if you're here please uh
counselor common cook
sorry about that yeah
often wonder about that um counselor
steve allman
yeah here chair counselor george herbs
here chair uh council alan curry
here chair councillor john dennis
here chair councillor pat moore
councillor moore that's pat moore
uh councilman mike garner i'm here chair
uh council david hart i'm sorry for him
i said it all thank you cedric yes i
will come to that under
um apologies thank you for that though
um councillor heather keane yeah chair
counselor paul moore present chair
uh counselor matthew scott
i am aware that he will be a few minutes
late because of his
work schedule uh councillor george
rosseski
president chair um welcome just very
quickly i know
you've taken over from councillor taylor
or gary taylor who
has left the council and i'd just like
to say
i know he found it difficult to with the
rescheduling of planning
but his dedication to the work he did
uh was what i saw and i'm sure other
members
and we've read his i know but was
excellent and this would be a sad loss
to
the authority uh council linda wright
yeah and i am so
uh thank you for that members um
right there's always a little bit of
housekeeping if i may
if you have any technical differences
during the meeting then please contact
democracy services
on call who will be to attempt
we'll be there to attempt to assist you
today's officer is
charles and his number is five double
seven
one eight six that number will go in the
chat box
and it will be included let's say in the
chat box your convenience i would ask
participants to mute your microphones
when you are not speaking
to minimize background noise and will
help everyone in
the meeting listen to the proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted permission
to speak
to gain permission please put a
notification
in the chat box on your right
and please wait until the other person
has finished speaking
but everybody present please ensure that
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls
once this meet is in progress please
also refrain from checking emails or
conducting any other business
and ensure that you are in a quiet room
free from
distractions for the duration of this
meeting
and again just to remind you that this
meeting has been
live streamed on the authorities
youtube channel
now to appoint uh members which um
i'm sure you are aware now um i know
this will be brought up at full
council next thursday uh but today
we've heard of the sad loss
of i think and i know many do
an unbelievable counsellor and that's
peter campbell
he um fought hard
with cancer and i understand
it wasn't just the cancer um
he got covered as well
uh this happened last night um it has
been made public
um so i'm not saying anything i
shouldn't be saying to any of you
uh at this meeting i would prefer
for nobody to comment
leave that to the proper place which
will be full council
as to say next thursday i think we all
feel
sadness and our regards go to
his family at this very sad time and if
we may if we can just bow our heads
just for a moment please
[Applause]
thank you members and i say i'm sure
we'll all have an opportunity those who
wish to say
a few words um
full council right moving on with agenda
members
requesting to speak under council
procedure rule
20.1 i have councillor pugh
for c land south of orchard
house sheriff's court lane ramsgate
councillor rogers four e
sportsman in one two three sandwich road
ramsgate also councillor raskin
for a sportsman in one two three
sandwich road i believe councillor bob
bayford
wishes to speak on item 4d if that has
been confirmed
i don't know if councillor bob is there
thank you members could make a note of
that thank you very much
um i have received gender item one have
received apologies
uh from councillor heart and that he's
been some he has been substituted by
councillor towning are there any more
apologies
hello um i i'd like just like to say uh
councillor
pat moore has um joined thank you very
much for that
councillor curry thank you
welcome council some more um
item two decorations of interest
are there any decorations of interest at
all
don't hear anything or see anything
agenda item three uh proving the minutes
um do members agree that the minutes of
the planning committee meeting held on
the 20th january
be approved could i have a proposal
please
thank you very much agenda item
4 schedule of planning applications and
public speaking
site visits once again as you're fully
aware
still cannot take place until all of us
get out of this uh
crazy situation we're all in and
to be staying safe the following items
have been reserved
for public speaking so if you could make
a note of this
agenda items 4a 4b
for c 4d and
4 e
thank you now i'm going over to a point
of information
and if our planning applications manager
mr livingston
would give us an update on two items
again if you're there please thank you
thank you
thank you chair um so just update on two
specific
agenda items so on agenda item 4c
which is the land south of orchard house
sheriff's court lane ramsgate
so subsequent to the publishing of the
agenda we've received a signed and
completed unilateral undertaking
which satisfies the requirement for
mitigation towards the
special protection area in line with
policy sp
29 and therefore on that application
the second recommended reason for
refusal
is is being removed from the officer
recommendation
however the recommendation remains the
same which is for refusal on the now
sole reason that's put forward by
officers
the second item is ready to follow up
the
um email that i sent to members last
week
um which is about agenda item 4d
which is kingsgate college convent road
broadstairs
um i raised point of information about
an error in the committee report
which states that the proposal is
departure from policy h01
so policy h01 of the of the new local
plan provides a list of sites where
housing will be granted as well as the
principle that
on non-allocated sites within the urban
and village confines that that the
proposals for residential
will be granted subject to meeting or
other relevant policy criteria
and therefore whilst the proposal is not
in accordance with that policy
but as the policy doesn't explicitly
state that no residential development
will be allowed outside the urban
confines it doesn't represent a
departure
from that policy so it's an important
technical point there
when proposals are outside the village
and urban confines they need to be
considered against policy
sp 24 which concerns development in the
countryside
and also any specific any site specific
designations and in this instance
it's the consideration against sp 25
which is
concerning the green wedges in phanet
thank you chair uh thank you for that
information
okay moving on to agenda item 4a
which is 179 percy avenue brawl stairs
um i will ask su suki to read out a
statement
um she has with a person who is
objecting to this
application thank you chair
this is a statement and objection from
mr baker firstly we would
just like to say that we fully
understand why our neighbors chris and
maxine
would like to go ahead with the
extension and that we only want to
ensure that alterations
made work out to be the best for both
party properties
here are the matters we would just like
raised
the height of the terrace both
properties at present have gardens which
are significantly lower
than the ground floor of the properties
and are accessed by steps going down
we are concerned that the proposed
neighboring terrace from the extension
will be too high and afford us a loss of
privacy of an
area of our garden which currently
cannot be easily viewed from the
neighboring property
we understand sorry we understood from
our neighbors that the original plans
showed an extension to the terrace by
two meters
was not what was intended the revised
plans
still show the two meter patio extension
which means that most people standing on
this will be head and shoulders
above fence level loss of light
we still feel the height and proximity
of proposed extension will significantly
obscure our dining room bay window
with regards to light and sky which
currently enhances
the character of the room privacy
screens on balcony
the revised plans do not indicate the
materials proposed for the privacy
screens
and we would appreciate the chance to
discuss what these are made from
as they will affect our property as much
as next door
thank you for listening to this
statement
uh thank you tuki uh i will now ask a
planning officer which is annabelle
to outline this application please
thank you chair i'll just share my
screen
um hopefully members can see my screen
yeah we can
thank you chair
so this is the application site 179
percy avenue
outlined in red as usual we have 177a
to the bottom of the application site
and the adjoining property is 181.
excuse me consent is sought for the
erection of a single story rear
extension
with a balcony at first floor level also
to the rear
and alterations the existing rays patio
area
and so just to show you some photographs
of the site this is the rear of the
application site
and central to the photograph here this
is 181
percy avenue 177 a
on the right hand side so looking at the
relationship between the application
site and 177
a which sits to the right here we can
see that 177a
has an existing extension here
and this is looking the other way um
with a better view of the relationship
between 179
um which is the application site and 181
um to the left of the photograph here
and this block plan is got obviously 179
centrally here
the sort of shaded orange area that you
can see here relates to actual built
form
so that would be the extension here
and the balcony with the dotted line
separating it would exist
in this location here which is the same
size of the
existing canopy that we've just seen in
the photographs
and here we can see the terraced area
which would project
some two meters beyond the proposed
extension
so we have the existing rear and
proposed rear elevations of the
properties
so we can see the canopy and arrangement
and the bay window
on the existing rear extension
and we can see the post extension in
situ here
with the balcony above the re-extension
would have a height of three meters
it would be six meters wide and have a
depth of 3.5 meters
and would be slightly set off from the
boundary of number 181
by approximately 0.2 meters
and this is existing side elevation
and this is a proposed side elevation so
we can see
again the balcony here with the privacy
screens
the ex proposed extension and the
terrace
coming off from the extension at this
level here
again we have the other side elevation
with a privacy screen again the teres
and the proposed extension
and we have in a section here which we
have the
balcony which would sit in the area of
the canopy that we've just seen
this is the extension here and this is
the terraced area
patio that continues and it would be at
a
two meters beyond the proposed extension
and you can also see the existing fence
line
that adjoins the proposed terrace area
here
so we have the existing ground floor
plan and the proposed ground floor plan
so you can see on the sorry the existing
ground for a plan on the left here
the bay window that is mirrored on the
adjoining property
and the canopy that sits currently over
that
bay window on the proposed
we have the proposed extension
and the patio that sits further forward
of it as has been mentioned
the proposal the post accenture would
have a depth of 3.5 meters
and then the patio area would sit
two meters beyond that um
members might be i would be advised that
under permitted development subject to
certain other criteria
um an extension of free meters could be
built without the need for
planning permission in this location
um just looking at the existing and
proposed first floor plans
so this is a canopy area here on the
first floor
as existing and this would be the
balcony
area which takes up the same space as
the canopy
and that is the flat roof of the
extension below and this is just to show
you the undercroft area of the patio
which
would be used for storage but not
habitable accommodation
to summarize this is the area here the
shaded area
is actual built form so the extension of
the balcony
and balcony would have the depth of the
1.5 meters which is the same as the
existing
canopy and the extension would
as a has been mentioned be have a height
of three meters
be six meters wide and have a depth of
3.5 meters
the revised the raised patio area sorry
would extend two meters beyond the
proposed extension
and would continue as the same height as
the current one
and it's not considered that would be
any significant change in the
relationship between the application
site
and 181 in terms of overlooking
them currently exists and clarification
has been requested
from the neighbor from the statement
that has just been read out
about the materials for the privacy
screens
sorry it is noted from the application
form that the proposed balcony would be
aluminum
aluminium minium and upvc
so tough and glass for the balcony and
it is expected that the screens
themselves would be the same
but obscure placed so the officer
recommendation is for approval
thank you annabelle i'm the same i can't
say that word aluminum
don't worry uh uh thank you and thank
you uh councillor scott um
uh for joining us and also i'm aware
that councillor pat moore is with us now
uh councillor alban you wish to speak
sorry before we go to speak i move the
officer's recommendation
be adopted as uh to approve could the
vice chair please
uh second i'll certainly thank you
thank you very much uh councillor alban
yes just one question chair um could the
officer revised
how high the boundary fence is
between the uh the two
properties so what the complainants and
and the development side please
can you do that annabelle yes bear with
me chair i'm just gonna
share my screen again to aid that
[Music]
um
sorry just bear with me i'll go back to
the section
um so with the section here
um here we have three meters in height
to the
top of the extension and
approximately looking at that we don't
have the exact height
measured but i would say that was about
1.5
so halfway between the three meters
and it is slightly higher as we saw from
the photographs
at this point here but that would
obviously be by the extent
uh blocked out by the extension so i'd
say the fence for joining the patio area
currently would be approximately 1.5
meters in height
okay thank you annabelle okay council
robin
thank you very much cheer thank you um
councillor paul moore please
yes thank you chair um from the planning
office's um
presentation she just showed us there um
obviously if you're stood on that um
decking area
you will be able to look over into the
neighbor's garden
and it will affect their privacy and you
could also look back
into their dining room area if you care
to look over and back
so when you mention approve with
subject to safeguarding conditions could
it not be a condition that
added screening like fenestration so
it allows light through but prevents
them overlooking
be added to that two meter decking area
so that the neighbors aren't overlooked
and their privacy is
is kept thank you
annabelle can you answer that yeah i can
come back on it certainly chair
um they you are able to build a
high offense there under permitted
development rights up to the height of
two meters
anyway and if members did wish to
consider a condition of that sort
i think it would be reasonable if
members did have concerns to impose
that that fencing is raised
okay thank you annabelle um are you
happy that counts some more
i'd be happy if we put the condition on
that the added fenestration
fencing is added to give the neighbors
uh their privacy rights yes
okay thank you um and i'm sure that can
be dealt with by annabelle
uh i don't have any other speakers
so i'm can i come back chair please of
course council
yes thank you um chair i'm i'm in
agreement with
councillor moore that's the the reason i
asked the question about the defense
height
um i believe it only needs approximately
uh
you know one or two fence panels of that
height
of a two meter height and i believe that
that will probably solve the situation
uh apart from that chair you know i'm
fully supportive of this application
thank you thank you for that councillor
alban okay
i can't see any other speakers um
apart from ian has just come in
mr livingston thank you thank you just
to come back on that point i think and
just for clarity
um obviously the motion that's currently
in front of members doesn't include
that condition um but obviously you've
heard what council organ and council
more
have said with regards to that i think
the one thing
i'd say is that um obviously the height
there
um obviously looks like it's sort of 1.5
above
the level of the patio um and therefore
as councilwoman says it may be just that
it needs to be increased up to about
1.8 meters above that patio
area um so in terms of procedure
um if the chair and vice chair as
the the the proposal of the motion and
the second
of the motion agree with the that
change then what just need to happen is
that if
those two parties agreed to remove the
current motion
and re-propose a motion to be
recommended and then subsequently voted
on
which would include a condition
requiring a boundary fence above the
height of the decking
to up to 1.8 meters then that would then
be the motion
that members would be voting on i do
think it's worth noting obviously that
um with an increased height of fencing
there would be an impact on the
neighboring property in a different way
in so much that you could you know it
could increase a sense of enclosure
and so uh but you know we can
you know potentially we can look at that
literally whilst the motion's being
removed we'll just i'll just quickly
have a look at the plans just to make
sure that we
would be okay and we're not
inadvertently creating an impact on the
neighbors
that whilst removing overlooking may
cause
a sense of enclosure uh thank you for
that ian um
counselor paul moore you wish to come
back
yes thank you chair um maybe on that
instance and maybe uh mr livingston
could uh
confirm this instead of having fencing
having like the shielding which is
angular so light is allowed to permeate
through
but vision isn't so it's angled in such
a way that light can still
go through the fencing to the neighbor's
property so they're getting maximum
light because that was one of the issues
they raised about light coming through
to their area lots of light
but it wouldn't necessarily be a a solid
a solid fencing and i think um mr
simpson will know what i'm talking about
thank you
thank you councilman uh councillor joel
bayford
thank you chair um yes just to say that
um i
i think that either of those options
would be
uh suitable and under those
circumstances i'd be very happy to
support the
application thank you thank you
councilman for
cancer robin yeah i just want to
just want to just want to double double
check it
they can put the the height of the
current fence
is 1.5 meters right
they can put a fence up to
two meters in height without requiring
any planning consent
so we could not really say put in what
councillor moore saying when they could
already
put up a two meter high fence which
would still block the light out or
whatever it is from
the net the next door so and they could
do that without requiring any planning
consent
and so um my view
chair is that we that uh
that a two meter high fence is the right
is
is is the right call thank you
right so i'm going to put this to you
uh members um oh sorry sorry chair if i
if i could
just from then on on that basis i think
it can just to clarify what members are
voting on
obviously at the moment the motion
doesn't have a condition i wonder
whether or not then given that what's
been discussed
whether or not um i i just think there's
a there's a
there's a relatively easy way of doing
this which is that if the motion is
withdrawn
and then if you come to me i will
propose a motion which will include
well i will mention to you a motion
which will update the current
recommendation which will include a
condition
which will require details to be
submitted prior to the development
commencing
effectively to just to confirm that
a boundary screening proposal to be
okayed by officers which would
encapsulate what members are are
requesting i think taking council
auburn's point about the
you can go up to two meters in high but
obviously the point here is about the
fact that the patio is higher than the
existing ground level
so whilst the actual boundary fence
could increase to two meters
the the decking is above that which may
still potentially mean
the effect you know taking the concerns
that have been raised
there could be the need for some sort of
negotiation around what exactly is
is is to be put in place to ensure both
the neighbors privacy and also light
but also a workable solution so if that
chimes with you chair that to withdraw
the motion and get councillor carmen
cook's agreement
then i'll i'll quickly outline a
condition here for you
thank you for that ian yes i was getting
not confused but i i understand and
thank
you council robin for your knowledge
there which i'm aware of uh
so um i'm going to put two
members that we withdraw this particular
motion
um i'll ask the vice chair to second
that please
i'll second that joe thank you and i
will then
obviously move to mr livingston to
put forward the new motion which we will
vote on
so just to confirm this is a motion to
approve the application
subject to safeguarding conditions to
include
uh details of a privacy screen
uh or boundary treatment um
with adjacent to the patio
area within the the rear extension
and the ground and that would be prior
to commencement development
and it'd be to safeguard the living
conditions of the neighboring property
and that's the ground of the condition
thank you
thank you for that ian um if members
understand that um i think that does
make sense
um so therefore i will propose
that and second again by the vice chair
i'll second that you thank you and i
will come
through yourselves um for members that
haven't sat with us before
i'll call your name out um
for that motion or against
or you're abstaining or please let me
know um
cancer comic before
cats are for councillor bayford
four councillor curry four
council dennis four
councillor ghana four
council towning four
councillor keen four councillor pat
moore
four councillor paul moore
four councillor zesky four
councillor scott i'm not staying in this
one chair thank you
okay counselor right
and myself i'm for that as well um
that that looking on my screen i'm sure
has
been carried and thank you for that
members and
mr livingston there uh we got there
thank you motion carry
right moving on to agenda item 4
b which is 4 14 7 stones driving brawl
says
i will ask our officer to
read out a public's statement in favor
of this application
thank you chair applicant statement in
support of application fth
201624 14 7 stones drive
broadstairs members are advised that
this is an application for a variation
of condition two
of planning consent fth191400
the current application fth201624
simply seeks to vary the width and
design of the front extension
the applicants feel strongly that the
proposals provide
a more attractive design that enhances
and complements the immunity of the area
for what is their forever family home
they have also been careful to discuss a
proposal with the only neighbours
that they considered would be affected
by this current proposal
it is considered that the previously
approved design featuring a cat slide
roof
to the front extension would detract
from the design of the proposals
as it is an unfamiliar design feature in
the vicinity
the applicant has therefore proposed an
amended design that establishes a degree
of symmetry to the front elevation
the proposal would be in accordance with
the design principles set
in policy d1 and would not conflict with
the aims
for the ahtv set in policy
d7 it would comply with policy 127 of
the national planning policy framework
which requires development to function
well and add to the overall quality of
the area
to be visually attractive as a result of
good architecture
and to be sympathetic to the local
character in history
including the surrounding built
environment and landscape setting
while not preventing or discouraging
appropriate innovation or change
such as increased densities there would
not be conflict with policy 130
of the framework as the development
would not be of poor
design that fails to take opportunities
available for improving the character
and quality of an area
and the way it functions the planning
officer has suggested that the latest
proposals would be detrimental
however an application was granted under
application fth0603
for a two-story side extension the
proposals had the result of closing the
gap between
16 and 15 seven stones drive in a
similar way
the extension had the effect of taking
the extension to the line of the garage
in the same way
as the proposals are shown on the
current application
the case officer is concerned that the
proposals would by virtue of the
increased width
lead to a diminution of quality but
there is simply no evidence of this
especially when a similar extension has
been approved nearby
the applicant would also like to draw
attention to the planning inspector's
appeal decision in respect of one
seven stones drive the inspector made
comparisons with the prominent position
of these proposals
not having any material effect upon the
amenity of the area
members are respectively asked to
support this application
and recommend approval in line with the
recommendations of the broad stairs
and saint peter's town council
thank you suki i will now ask the
planning officer which is once again
annabelle
to give her report please
well thank you chair
um hopefully members can see my screen
okay
thank you this is the application site
number 14
seven stones drive it's at the end of
the cul-de-sac
and it's outlined in red as usual
as as has been mentioned planning
permission it was previously granted for
a variety of it
front side and rear extensions as well
as
alterations to materials to the property
and additional on-street parking
and this application seeks to make
changes to that consent
and they include um internal
revisions to the internal layout
alterations to fenestration
removal of previously approved chimney
stacks
and alterations to materials the
widening of the front
extension as well as the riding of the
front extension
sorry this is the
some photos of the application site so
this is number 14
here at the end of the cul-de-sac number
12
is this adjoining property here and this
is number 15.
um this is a closer view of number 14
and you can see the sort of regularity
and whilst they do not mirror each other
these properties they have elements and
a degree of consistency between them
and so standing in front of number 14
you can see the extension here
sorry the balcony is existing here the
garage the flat roof
and this is number 12 and you can see
that number 14 sits
slightly fractionally in front of number
12. so again we can see
number 12 here and properties running
away from it this is the edge of the
application site here
and you can see the garage and again you
can see
the fact that it does sit forward of
number 12
and again this is number 14 on the left
hand side of the photograph here
and you can see its relationship with
number 15.
and this gives sort of standing at the
edge
upper side of the cold edge of the
cul-de-sac so you can see number 12 here
the space between it and number 12
sorry number 14 in centrally in the
photograph and its garage
and the landscaping and the relationship
between
the application site and number 15.
i will draw members attention to the
fact that officers are
content with all the proposed
alterations except for the widening
of that front extension and increase of
width
on above the garage and we will look at
that when we review the plans
and sorry the last photograph before we
move on to the plans this is the rear of
the application site
so this is um the application site
and the hatched area up area shows the
extensions that have already been
approved
and that this consent will seek to vary
and this so the hatched areas are all
extensions
this was the existing parking area that
we've just seen and this was an
additional parking air which was all
allowed
on the previous consent
so this is the front elevation as we've
just seen
and this is the front elevation that has
been approved under the previous
application
and the area as i say there are some
changes to fenestration and things
between
this and the application as it currently
stands
but members officers are not concerned
about those or the internal
layout or alterations materials what met
officers have concerns about is this
area here
so this is what has been previously
approved
this is what they are now proposing to
do so
it will increase in width and come
much closer to the edge of the garage
this is the existing side elevation
and this is the improved side elevations
you can see
some of the extensions are already being
approved and again
this is the elevation that's been
proposed again you can see
some of the additional elements or
changes to fenestration but it is this
area
here that we are looking at in terms of
the changes
so the existing rear elevation the rear
elevation has
approved so you can see the
extensions that have been approved but
this is the area that we draw
members attention to because this is the
area
of concern to officers
so you can see here the extension has
grown and this is the area
that we consider to be encroaching
further across the garage
so this is the other side extension
as it originally existed as approved on
the previous application
and now as proposed
so looking at the ground floor this was
this it is existing
and this is the the application was
approved so you can see some of the
extensions that wrap around the existing
parking area and the
extended parking area this is the first
floor is existing
so this is the garage that sticks out
prominently here
and this is what was approved
in the previous application
so you have the master bedroom this area
is still garage
and the balcony etc and you can see the
wrap-around extensions that we've seen
previously and this is what is now being
proposed
so the master bedroom essentially
increases in width
sorry bear with me
so concerns are however raised about
this extension
and the increase in width
of the and we can see it here on the
front extension
whilst the increase is fairly minor in
terms of scale
being 0.7 in width it is considered that
this increase would alter the pattern of
development in this part of seven stones
drive
particularly in terms of the visual and
physical gaps between the properties
and this is particularly emphasized by
the fact that number 14 does sit forward
of number 12
and there are slight changes in levels
and slightly increasing as you come up
to
number 14. so the offer officer
recommendation
is that although most of the alterations
proposed
in this application are acceptable the
increase in the width of the
excuse me master bedroom above the
garage here
is considered to be unacceptable so the
recommendation is for refusal
thank you thank you annabelle i move the
officer's recommendation is adopted
could the vice chair please second
oh second nurture thank you very much
um council robin
yeah thank you chair um
as this prophecy is is at the end of the
cold sack and not
at the uh not in the middle of the
row of houses i really can't see this
0.7
increase has any effects either on a
street scene or
or against any other or affects the
neighbours so
for me chair i i'm um
i'm in favor of of giving approval thank
you chair
thank you casserolver and council
bayford thank you chair
um i do agree i i i actually think
it looks more balanced um with the
increased
um extension um i've also i've also
added the fact that it's on a corner
um and there's plenty of space and i
really can't see
how that this would cause any problems
at all about the appearance of the area
so i i
really feel i can't agree with refusal
on this one
thank you thank you uh councillor paul
moore
yes thank you chair um all the comments
that i was going to make have already
been
uh muted by council auburn and
councillor bayford
i think it adds to the symmetry it's 0.7
of a meter
it's far enough away from that building
although it's it's projected fall on the
building line
they're not tight plots it will have no
adverse effect on the neighboring
property
and and who wouldn't want to increase
their master bedroom over their garage
area
i think it it it blends in very well so
i would be for approval thank you
thank you councillor moore um i don't
see any other speakers so i'm going to
put
the officer's recommendation to you
which is
this stage to refuse and as
you know the ropes by now uh then
obviously
if that fails um not coming back to you
so uh
councillor coleman cook uh
i'm not sure i am uh for
this um so extension
so you're against the action yes
yeah thank you again sorry if i
misunderstood anyone if you
say the recommendation from officers is
to refuse
if you're not happy with that please say
you're against
uh council robin yeah against council
bayford
against councillor curry
against uh councillor dennis
okay councillor ghana
against councillor towning against
councillor keane against
councillor patmore against
councillor paul moore against
councillorski against
councillor scott against
council right against and i will go with
yourselves
so that motion has been
lost so we need a motion to put forward
to approve
um and do you wish to come back or
thank you chad just all i would just say
is that in terms of when proposing the
motion to approve
if uh the respective counselor when
putting that forward could just
elaborate
uh from what we've heard it's to
recommend approval because the property
the proposal doesn't harm the character
appearance of the area
yeah so i thought um
there were several but uh if i come to
i would propose that chair council paul
moore
okay uh could i have a second on that
please yeah i'll say connect yeah that's
relevant
right thank you councilwoman once again
i know i have to do this
for the record i will have to go through
names once again
uh so in this case if you're for the
amendment or against or abstain
uh please say so um council common cook
four counts robin four councillor
bayford
four councillor curry four
council dennis four council ghana
four count the town in four
councillor keane four councillor pat
moore
four counselor paul moore four
councillor zesky four councillor scott
for council right four
and that includes me i'm four as well
that was unanimous and the motion
has been approved uh thank you for that
members
uh now moving on to a general item
for c uh the lander
orchard house shares called lane in
ramsgate
i will ask suki once again to read out
a statement in favor of this application
thank you thank you this presentation is
given by the applicant and his wife
mr and mrs holbrook this application has
been made to build a home for our
daughter and family
who currently live with us in orchard
house
they moved into our home when she was
diagnosed with cancer two weeks after
giving birth
so we could offer them our full support
during treatment and ongoing recovery
as a result our home is now cramped and
overcrowded and our grandson has reached
the age where he needs his own bedroom
longer term this close proximity will
enable
our daughter and her family to offer us
the support to remain living in our home
into old age and in the meantime we can
continue to support
with child care no objections have been
received from anyone
including our neighbours and minster
parish council
permission has recently been granted for
a pair of two-story
semi-detached properties to the north
within yards of our boundary
and where we once looked at trees we now
look at a large expanse of roof
as you will see from the photographs
included in the application
our intention is to build a quality
eco-friendly home
that is sympathetic to the environment
starting with the fabric of the building
including high performance glazing grey
water system
air source heat pump and pv panels this
is especially important to us
as our intention will be to stay in
sheriff's court lane for many years
for our own privacy we will be screening
the property from the lane
also providing a barrier from the heavy
vehicles that
regularly go past to and from the farm
and industrial units at the end of the
lane
we fully understand that personal
circumstances rarely justify development
but in this case the circumstances are
entirely relevant
as the only other option available to us
is to site a mobile home on the garden
to be used for ancillary purposes
and for which we are advised that no
planning permission would be required
but would not only be far less
attractive it would provide our daughter
and her family
with a much lesser standard of
accommodation and living
we also appreciate the provision of one
dwelling is small scale
in terms of the council's housing
delivery policy
but we are not developers looking to
make profit just a family wishing to use
our land to provide a forever home
[Music]
uh thank you very much suki um i now
call upon
councillor pew who i believe is online
who is the wall council wishes to speak
council pew
yes thank you chair um i will i will try
and be brief as i appreciate that
there's many applications to uh
to consider today um i'll try and touch
on a few points but not
go over what the applicant and the
applicants have already stated in their
statement
um i understand the reasons that are
given for refusal particularly
potential impact on the countryside and
the rural character of the area
but quite honestly knowing the area as i
do and as one of the ward councillors
and
i've probably been down sheriff's court
lane almost as much as the residents
that live down there
um which is nestled almost slap bang in
the middle of
moncton and minster along moncton road
and
moncton street um quite honestly i would
say the sheriff called lane
and you know in normal circumstances i
i'd argue for a site visit to be honest
so that
uh committee members could appreciate um
the site in the area for what it is um
but these quite sparsely populated
um as the applicant has mentioned in
their statement there have been no
objections particularly from
minster parish council or from moncton
parish council as well
um all from residents in the neighboring
vicinity because there are so few
um but also as well you know this is a
local family that wants to stay together
and i understand that the personal
circumstances this cannot be attributed
and have weight in this application
but in all honesty i mean this isn't an
applicant that wants to split the land
and make a profit
as we see in in other areas um where
there's a property with a large plot of
land
um and quite honestly if permission is
if permission isn't granted i think the
alternative is for the family to
to cite a caravan on the land which will
have a much more detrimental impact
on uh the long-standing views and the
rural character
and you know just to provide a bit of
context across the road on the main road
from from where this site is there's a
collection of elm trees
um which one of the parish councils from
minster is doing a bit of investigation
at the moment
because um they have a have a feeling
that they might be a new species of
illness
of planet elm trees which is quite
exciting so you know i do appreciate
the the rural character and then and the
nature and the risk of
this impacting on across the countryside
but but quite honestly you know the area
is so past as fastly populated as it is
um i think the greater need for us to
allow buildings to be built in areas
such as this and as the applicant said
two houses have been given permission
right next to it which you know
if that's the concern is the impact on
long-standing views and the rural
character of the area then they
shouldn't have
received consent um it's my view that
it's better that
this is given permission and that it the
development or
new developments are concentrated in the
area rather than spread out
um you know quite honestly because i
just think that you know
let's be honest we're building on almost
every bit of agricultural land we can
um you know and i think one house here
isn't really going to make much of a
difference to the impact on the area
but that's uh that's just my view so i
would urge urge councillors
to uh approve this application
uh thank you for that uh council who um
i now ask uh mr livingston to give his
report please
thank you chair i'll just uh present my
screen
okay hopefully you can see the screen
so uh the application site is
outlined in red so the application is
for the erection of a detached two-story
dwelling uh the main issues to consider
for members are the principal
development
the impact on the character and
appearance of the countryside living
conditions
highways and all other general material
considerations
so the site is located outside the open
confines as already mentioned
it's along the the moncton road and
moncton street that connect
the connect minster and moncton members
will be familiar
from a few months ago with the who farm
site
uh which is just here uh the application
site is down sheriff's court lane
here um so this uh is an
aerial image of the site uh just to pick
up the point with regards to the
two dwellings that that's been mentioned
by both the applicant and councillor pew
that relates to this site here which
is actually an application for tutorings
that came before members as well
so um that was the plan so it was to put
two dwellings in between the existing
properties
here so the proposed site for a new
dwelling is in this location
here so this
is a view looking north from sheriff's
court
sheriff court lane uh towards the site
so you can see orchard house in the
background there
this is just a closer in view at the
moment so you can see the current
boundary treatment in place
uh so this isn't just another view
showing that the designer style
of orchard house
then this is the view looking back
towards the site
um so you can see it's a raised ground
level here
um for where the the to the actual
highway itself
uh and you can see again through the
mist the countryside
beyond and this is just another view so
you can see there goes the lane down on
the right hand side of the image there
um and you can see the backdrop of the
countryside in that image
and this is just a few back up um
uh sheriff's called lane just to show
that see we are looking at a lane there
is no
there are no footways either side uh of
the property so it's it is a site that
is reliant as the
previous site uh for the two houses
awards it is reliant on
on private modes of transportation
so this is the site plan of the proposed
dwelling so it is proposed to utilize
the existing
access into auction house to then access
this area here for for parking and
turning
uh with the dwelling located to the
south of orchard house
so this is the elevation that uh would
front
um the lane and so you can see it's a
uh we've got pitched roof style with
with dorm windows fronting on that
elevation then
this is the south facing elevation
so if you remember the view we were
looking to the north
from the images so you can see it's a
two-story property
with pitched roofs
this is the view to the east
and then this is the the front elevation
so it faces
orchard house as part of the proposal
uh and this is the so this is the ground
floor plan
and then the first floor plan so it's a
four bedroom property that's being
proposed
and then the roof so roof plants are
just showing the different
roof forms that are present
so this is a section provided by the
applicant
so you can see that what's being
proposed on the just going on the
plan at the bottom of the image uh you
can see that the highway level so there
is a
slight increase but there is going to be
some some reduction in that in the
level of that garden but it's still
above the highway
level um you can also see they've
included the section of orchard house
which we've seen to show that
the proposed welding wouldn't be any
higher than the orchard house
and also they have included the the
dwellings
that have previously been approved
and so officers consider um that
the open section of garden that would be
built on
does relate to the countryside and the
landscape character areas in particular
in an officer's view we do feel it would
be
clearly visible and set against the open
countryside
which is contrary to the defining
characteristics of both the landscape
character and also
harming the intrinsic value of the
countryside
so it does result in harm to the
environmental dimension
of sustainable development now
there is obviously a situation as
outlined last committee
where the council is um currently
looking at development on the basis of
the presumption of in favor of
sustainable development
for development outside the urban
confines and therefore forced to
consider whether or not
any harm created demonstrably outweighs
the benefits
in this instance obviously the the
benefits
that are cited about having an
additional dwelling uh whilst
limited it's it's still an additional
dwelling just to pick up the
personal circumstances um that have been
have been mentioned
um they they haven't admittedly hasn't
been submitted as part of the
application but
just to come back on that um it's not
considered that
personal circumstances do outweigh any
harm to the countryside on this sort of
basis
because whilst it's understood that
personal circumstances are clearly
obviously important to the current
occupants
um we are in a situation where this
would be physical development
which will be lasting long past any
proposed occupants would be present
in the property um and and therefore
it is considered that you know that
there is harm there that would not be
outweighed by personal circumstances
i just want to pick up the point as well
with regards to the the
sighting of the mobile home um and this
is covered in the officers report
um obviously the proposes for a
two-story permanent structure
which would in in you know officers
minds
create more of an impact than a
single-story mobile home which could be
cited
under permitted development rights
so it is considered that whilst there
may be a fallback process
uh sorry a fallback um in place uh that
the development
would be materially different from that
fallback and would cause
additional harm to the character and
appearance of the countryside
as i mentioned the point of information
um the contribution for the
spa and sam's um has has been covered
but when weighing up the benefits of the
scheme against
the harm to the countryside it is
considered by officers
that those harms do outweigh the
benefits outlined
and therefore the application is
recommended for refusal
thank you chair uh thank you even now
i moved at the officer's recommendation
is adopted uh could the vice chair
please
second oh second nature thank you
council coleman cook
uh does any member wish
to speak on this
council a few coming in now yes i
thought there would be a
council paul moore yes thank you chair
um could i just confirm that because
this is a two-story building
and therefore uh affects the the skyline
of the countryside
that's one of the reasons why this um is
being refused
if it was a single story dwelling would
it have had
as much impact or would it have had a a
more
uh favorable conclusion to that first
thank you
ian can you yes so um
i mean the um whilst we obviously
haven't considered a single story
proposal i think it's
it's inevitable that the impact would be
lessened
in terms of the impact on um the sense
of openness that's created by this site
and its relationship with the
countryside
um it's difficult to say that say a
single story dwelling would be
acceptable
because obviously without the design of
it and the footprint of it
and those sorts of things but i think
the scale of the building
certainly is one of the elements that
officers
do feel results in the harm
uh thank you uh council robin
yeah i'm a bit torn with this to be to
be honest um
whilst i've i'd obviously recognize that
the the infield of
the new buildings um was
the right decision that we made
um this would kind of
round off if you like the um
the block of of houses along cherish
lane
um but
at the same time i don't particularly
uh like the design of the building i
just think uh
i just think it would look odd there but
anyway that's just my
that's just the view i have can i a
question i'd
um as part of um
the reading out from the um owners
or their agent um they're saying
it's going to be like a green uh you
know a very green
house uh for um heating and stuff of
that nature and
and and that's the way that they want to
go which is which is great
but i did notice that there is a chimney
um
is that is i mean if you're going green
why why the hell do you want a chimney
um so
it's just a silly point but um
can you advise if that if that is an
open fireplace
please uh ian can you do that
um i'm just looking at
the plans i mean it's it's shown
on the let me just sorry let me just
present my screen bear with me
um i mean it's it's shown as open
fireplace i think
the thing that i would say with regards
to this as a point i mean whether or not
it's
decorative rather than use and obviously
we're talking about the internal layout
so the controls so there's the living
room
you can see obviously they've shown what
looks like fireplace whether or not it's
a
you know it it's it is something that's
not necessarily controlled in terms of
whether or not a wood burner is put in
there if it's obviously going up the
exist that the chimney stack has
proposed
i i think it's one thing that i would
say is that with any new dwelling
that's approved in the district there is
a requirement and a condition that's
imposed
which requires at least an equivalent of
code level
4 for sustainable homes which includes
issues to do with
energy efficiency and water efficiency
and pollution and those sorts of
requirements which are covered under
part l of the building regulations so
in terms of the weight to be given to
um the property being is efficient you
know we haven't
got i don't think any details of that
that would
um add further weight uh to the benefits
of the proposal
and again i would still put forward the
the harm to the general countryside
still results in
a net harm on the environmental
dimension of sustainable development
okay thank you chair uh thank you and uh
council towning
yeah i i'd like to take it up from where
counselor paul mall
actually we talked about a single story
uh dwelling
uh i think that is an option that you
know should be actually thrown back at
the applicant
and asked you know would they reconsider
the design and plan
because if if we really consider this
application much closely
i mean firstly there is a family
requirement
of an ongoing situation what i
appreciate ian it doesn't form
part of planning there is a need to be
flexible
i mean the entire country countryside
is up uh being butchered apart and i
think here is an opportunity for
you as planners to go back and say we
can look at this on a sympathetic basis
and look at the possibility of how
a design that would fit in as a single
story
and a design that would not impact as
you keep saying
on the on the local environment
uh and the countryside i i strongly
would suggest that
uh thank you council towning i'm sure
ian could
look at that but i'm coming back to
council paul moore
uh you wish to add
some more yes thank you chair um i think
cancer towning has just uh
hit on that as i was going to reaffirm
um
if if it's a size and mass that we're
concerned about
and a single story dwelling lowers the
profile
of the street scene is there any
restrictions that they can go down
so they could have a floor beneath the
basement area so they could still have
their two-story building
but they would dig down it might be more
costly for them
um but at least they would gain what
they're trying to achieve
and it's just a suggestion that if we're
not happy with the design and we're not
happy with size and mass
then maybe we can go back to them and
say look this is something maybe you
want to look at
thank you chad
i think on if i may account for more i
think obviously
depends on the vote on this what happens
after that
not for us really to get involved in
suggestions
to the applicants and so on uh
councillor bayford
thank you chair um i'm also torn on this
one
um i i don't like to see um further
development in the countryside
but as councillor auburn said um this
extra house
does seem to round off the line of
houses i don't actually have a problem
with the design of it um
i find it quite difficult to see the
harm that this would cause i
i'm not in any way considering the
personal circumstances because i don't
think
they should be taken into account but um
i really can't see on an ongoing basis
why this will cause a problem in the
future
thank you uh thank you so bad for the
council
yes um really just what councilman
bayford has said i don't feel that this
causes
a particularly negative impact on the
environment
um with the group of houses that are
there already
so i'm intending towards um supporting
the proposal the proposal for
not the officer's recommendation
thankfully
and thank you for that counselor keen i
was going to ask you then but you've
done
it for me um i can't see any other
comment or speakers so
right as usual i'm going to put this to
you members
i move the officer's recommendation is
adopted and that is refi
for refusal uh could the vice chair
please second
or second that uh okay thank you
uh i will go through yourselves once
again members
if you're for refusal please say four
against obviously against her
or abstain um because the common cook
against council alban
have we lost councillor alban
i'll come back to council auburn
councillor
joe bayford against councillor curry
against council dennis
against council ghana
for council towning
uh against uh council mckean
against councillor pat moore
against council paul moore
against councillor scott
against chair councillor zesky
against council of rights against
myself i'm against as well um i'll come
back to council auburn in fairness
i used their account i pressed the wrong
button and i went off
i did say i was for the officer's
recommendation thank you chair
right um okay
i'm just looking at um counselor
garners
thank you yeah i was just i mean
obviously
another motion is going to be put in
front of us
to um approve the application
yes it's concerned that before that's
done
um if we just do that to vote for a
motion to approve there won't be any
conditions
that some of the usual conditions that
are on applications when they're
approved
and a number of other conditions that
might be appropriate
for this um application you know these
are standard ones like
developments got to be started
i don't understand what you're getting
at and uh i'm sure ian knows i'm going
to ask him um
if he a nice smile there in um
yes sorry if i yeah if i could come back
to this so um
so under usually under delegated
authority when when
applications are approved by members
sometimes we are explicit in saying
approved and so subject to safeguarding
conditions um obviously
to clarify when when applications like
this are approved we would look to be
explicit in
them if if a member could be explicit in
the motion to stay subject to
safeguarding conditions because
as i mentioned one of the conditions
would be you know about equivalent
code level sustainable uh homes level
four
uh there's water efficiency conditions
there's the standard materials
you know there's all sorts of conditions
that we've normally put on
not overly restrictive um but the
standard conditions would put on and if
i could check
may i come back following the vote as
well yes by all means
okay so obviously hearing the comments
of
um of members i've seen a few fear in
terms of suggestions of a a reduction in
height but however i think that there is
you know a point here which a number of
members have commented that actually the
development
on its own as it is is considered
acceptable
um i think as per as with the previous
vote on on seven stones drive
it's just important that whoever
proposes the motion one if recommending
if putting forward a motion for approval
mentions to subject to safeguarding
conditions
but also gives the ground of approval to
go against the recommendation
and in that instance what i've heard
members say
um is is with regards to um
is with regards to the fact that it's
not considered that the development
would result in
significant harm to the countryside or
the landscape character area
um by you know and that and that is
effectively the reason why
the development is considered to be
acceptable uh i've just seen in the chat
if i again not to take too much
advantage of of the microphone but i've
just seen
one of the points raised with regards to
conditions um
a standard condition would would include
details
of landscaping to be provided and
obviously this proposal
does propose hedging around the edge of
the property to reinforce the boundary
of the site which would be a requirement
of any approval
i think just to clarify that thank you
chair thank you and yes i noticed
councillor ghana's
um condition there that i hope that's
been asked for your council ghana
right obviously um back to your sales
members i
would like a proposal for approval
um you've heard of the comments from mr
livingston
um could i have a proposal please i
propose that chair councillor paul moore
councilman moore could i have a second
to please i'm happy to second that
you're beaufort thank you councillor
bayford again
uh if you're for please say so
against or abstain uh councillor coleman
cook
for councillor alban against
councillor bayford council curry
four council dennis against
council ghana against
council town in four
councillor keane four councillor pat
moore
four councillor paul moore four
councillor scott four
councillor zesky abstain
council right four
and i'm going to have stayed on this one
a bit of a difficult
decision on this but uh i believe that
motion has been
carried thank you james it has thank you
members
right gender item for d
uh kingsgate college convent road uh
prostes
uh once again i'm coming back to suki
keeping it busy tonight
sookie
she has some more statements to read out
for you which are
in favor of this application yes um
there is no name at the top of this
statement but i will read it out
the proposed conversion of the former
kingsgate college will result in the
reuse of a disused building in need of
repair
although just outside the current
development boundary the site has
previously developed land
in a sustainable location with numerous
community facilities within easy walking
distance
and bus stops close to the site these
facilities include the neighboring golf
club whose restaurant and bar
are likely to appeal to golfers and
non-golfers alike
the proposed modifications to footprint
and built volume
are very minor in nature whilst the
conversion of an existing building
represents a sustainable reuse of land
the proposal also includes measures that
will create or enhance wildlife habitats
and biodiversity as officers has
confirmed the proposed conversion is not
detrimental or contrary to
any of the full stated aims of the green
wedges policy
we consider that the proposals fully
accord with the local plan
whilst the previous use of the site was
educational the development is not
considered to result in the loss of a
community facility
as did not previously serve the local
community
in any event there is no reasonable
prospect of an educational use returning
to the property
and it is therefore essential that best
use is made of the building
the proposed conversion allows the
building to be repaired and put back
into productive use future homes has an
excellent track record of delivering
high quality housing
in and around thailand so you can be
assured that these apartments will be
delivered quickly
and contribute to the council's housing
supply without unnecessary delay
a contribution has also been agreed to
help boost affordable housing
locally as a result it is respectfully
requested that planning permission
be granted thank you very much uh suki
um
speaking under council rules 20.1 is
more councillor
councillor baker bob bayford
thank you chairman uh as you know i'm a
very rare visitor to planning so i
wonder if you could just explain to me
uh exactly what defer and delegate means
does it mean in fact uh once it's
delegates to officers they have the
ability to make changes to the
application
i'll come to in on that um i do know but
um uh thank you chair um so it's
deferring delegate for approval
subject to conditions but and also the
the
agreement of a legal agreement to secure
the heads of terms as outlined in the
report
so it wouldn't result in changes to the
proposal
in terms of plans etcetera okay
well are you happy that you're not
survivor uh not happy chairman but uh
better informed so
thank you for that thank you um i mean
whenever i see uh anything uh that's in
the green wedge my hackles rise
and they did with this one and in my
ideal world
i would like to see the old building
demolished
and the land put back to nature but
quite clearly that isn't going to happen
uh councillor bayford we've lost you you
suddenly muted
and it wasn't me that did that counselor
bamford
i'm not sure i believe you chairman but
there we are i don't know where i've got
to now
um i mean other than saying that you
know don't like to see development in
the green wedge i mean i can appreciate
the buildings are already there
and to be perfectly honest uh derelict
building sitting in there would be
an eyesore and would detract from from
what's going on
i take or i trust that the officers
are actually looking for this to be a
sensitive as it can be
i take the point that uh it is in the
green wedge but
probably isn't doing anything to detract
from the green wedge and that is really
important i mean it's absolutely vital
that the wedges are protected
um but i feel under the circumstances
uh that you know that there is going to
be something there
my suppose one of my concerns is and i
know it's not something that really
anything can be done about but
i just hope that the granting of
permission for this there
can't then be used as some kind of
precedent which allows other people to
come
along and want to put things in the
green which we know the green wedge is
under threat
there have been a number of applications
recently that
fortunately as far as i'm concerned have
been turned down there will be others
coming
and as i say i think this has to be
viewed as a total exception
and if it is then uh then i expect
that that it has to be thank you chair
uh thank you councilman for totally
understand uh your comments there
um okay um i'll ask
annabelle i think he's once again
pleased to give her report
yes thank you chair i'll just present
excuse me members um this is the
application site
outlined in red we have covent road
convent road sorry
running top to bottom along here
and north fallen golf course with its
buildings and car park to the top of the
site here so the application is um for
the change of use of the existing
college building
to 18 apartments it would be 15 two bed
and three
free bed units and there would be some
alterations and extensions to the
building
to facilitate this change of use
so this is an aerial photo view of the
site
um again you can see the existing
building here
some existing hard surfacing and we have
the golf course um to the north here
it clearly shows from this photograph
the amount of landscaping that is
some within the site but also in the
surrounding area
so much so that you can barely see
convent road itself which
runs up along there it is noted that
trees in this location and this part of
the site
and some on the opposite side of convent
road are actually covered by a tpo
and it has as has been mentioned the
site is in the countryside and also
within the green wedge
so i'll just show you some photographs
of the site
there with me this is the existing
access to the site
so these trees that you can see along
here are actually covered by the tpo
so moving in further into the site this
is the front of the building and you can
see the existing hard surfacing
and again this is further into the site
so this is the main entrance to the
building
and again you can see the hard surfing
surfacing that already exists
on the site
and now we're just moving around the
building as we've seen is kind of an l
shape with a large expanse here and a
small expanse
running along this boundary here and
again you can see the hard surfacing
some out buildings and a sort of
transition
between the hard surfacing
and the sort of more green part of the
site that we'll see in a moment
so this is this outbuilding that we saw
on the previous
photo and the edge of the hard surfacing
is here
the building is off to the left of this
photo and this is a sort of
landscaping more green area of the site
that exists currently
and this is looking again back to the
southern
part of the site which was part of the
kingsgate college site
but doesn't actually form part of the
application site
but you can again see the trees along
there
and it is quite um enclosed by trees as
we've already seen
so again we're taking a um
a look at the rear of the application
site at this point in time
so you can see there are differences in
levels here and a number of dormer
windows
and things like that to the rear of it
but again you can see just on the edge
here that there are trees and things and
the golf course
sits and with its car park to the left
of this photo
so again we have the site plan so this
is existing the existing access which is
here this is the building so this is the
main bulk of the building
and the bit that sort of comes off the
area of hard
surfacing is here and you can see the
number of trees
that exist as mentioned previously
this is the area that we are considering
as the application site
the main sort of grassed area we saw in
the photographs earlier
is this bit below here so it doesn't
actually form
full within the application site so this
is the proposed site plan
excuse me this again is the main
building
as you can see and the flank here this
is the hard surfaced area
and which will again be utilized for car
parking as it was
in turn in the time of the former
college
um there are some extensions we will
look at when we look at the floor plans
but the main sort of extension and
buildings that aren't
sort of um are additional which would
form in the green wedge
are an extension here which is where the
garages that we saw in the photographs
are
and there is a bin and bike store and
also a carport
which would be on the existing hard
surfaced area
so this is the existing southwest
elevation which is the front elevation
as we've seen
so there's the fire escape we saw
the main sort of front entrance and this
is the proposed
front of the building um again this is
how
has limited changes to the front it
is proposed to be a contemporary more
modern
um refitting of the building and it
would
keep its main focus of the front
elevation
and front entrance way and
this is a southeast side elevation
as existing and this is proposed
again you can see it is updated and
become
more contemporary in nature and there
are terraces
and more modern materials
utilized to give it an uplift and bring
it back into a sort of
more modern and contemporary building
this is the rear elevation um as
existing
this is the sort of glaze conservatory
element we saw in the photographs and
the dormers that we saw
this is the proposed rear elevation and
this is where most of these sort of
extensions
happen um and we'll see that on the
floor plans but some of the
um elements are squared off and this
element here isn't
a bit of an extension as you would have
seen but again
it is well screened by um vegetation
and this is not new footprint as such
just
uh alterations and minor extensions of
the existing building
so this is the other side elevation and
you can see the two
garages that we looked at when we saw
the photographs
and this does change and it does have an
extension
um here which provides additional units
but that is considered to be seen
against the built form that is already
on site
and not to provide a big expanse of new
development within the green wedge
excuse me turning to the floor plans now
so if the existing basement
here and that will be used in the
proposed development to be the plant
room
and the existing ground floor and as you
can see
if i briefly draw your attention members
attention to it
there are some areas where the building
line particularly to the rear
dips in and out so looking at the
proposed
ground floor plan you'll see that some
of these elements are squared off
so again it is extensions to the
building in the green wedge but they are
considered minor and
enable the building to be fully used and
the ground floor here would provide
seven flats and this is the first floor
as existing and this is the proposed
first floor
and again you can see there are
extensions and
of things along here and these the
extensions we've just seen but they will
be used to provide
terracing and amenity space for the
units here
and this floor would provide enough for
eight
units this is the existing second floor
plan
and this is the proposed second floor
plan again you can see
it would provide the final free units
and there would be elements of terracing
and outdoor space of effectively to
serve those units
the existing route planning number of
roof lights
and again the proposed roof plan
um as mentioned there are a number or
three additional buildings that would be
located on site this is a carport
and so you can see the floor plan and
its elevations
it will also house
the plant for the electric vehicle
charging points
and would be single storey as you can
see here and
would sit on the existing area of hard
standing
and then we have the proposed bin store
with floor plan and elevations
and we have the proposed bike store
and just to give you some visualize
artist impressions that have been
provided
so this would be coming into the site
this is the main
elevation entrance that we've seen to
the front here
this is the flank that would be changed
slightly
as in this proposal and this is um
a visualization of the rear um as if you
were standing in the golf club car park
and to summarize the application site is
clearly within the countryside
and within the green wedge but as has
been mentioned the scheme would reuse an
existing building
with minimal extensions and alterations
and it's not considered um to result in
any adverse impact on the countryside
or the green wedge although there are
some limited additional built forms by
way of the carport
and the bin store and um bike store
and this extension here that although it
replaces
existing built form in the form of the
double garage it is
higher than what is there now
um originally the application had a
footpath that ran
sort of from here into the trees that
exist here
and out onto convent road and that did
result in a number of trees
or an impact on existing trees and
potentially the loss of some of those
trees
that footpath has now been removed from
the scheme
and only one of protected tree
which is a sycamore would be lost
in this application now and that is to
allow
the refuge vehicles to safely access the
site
but all of the other trees will be
retained on site
additional planting is also proposed
particularly along
this boundary here which we saw
previously was open from the photographs
and this additional been planting has
been welcomed by the council's
agricultural officer
and he considers um that the species
proposed are acceptable and they will
have been visually
and increase its biodiversity
no impact no sorry no adverse impact on
living conditions of adjoining residents
because essentially there
aren't many around but it would provide
a good standard of
accommodation for future occupiers
and there is a requirement for the sand
contribution
to be paid and kcc contributions to
education
community warming youth services
libraries horse care
and waste and in this instance also
affordable housing is
um being dealt with by a contribution
for off black provision
and he's been agreed with the applicant
and so given the the above the officer
recommendation is to defer and delegate
for approval subject to the receipt of
the completed undertaking for those
required contributions
thank you annabelle i i move that the
officer's
recommendation is adopted and as you
heard it's to defer
and delegate with the vice chair police
second
or second manager thank you um
i have mike garner council ghana please
thank you very much yeah i've just got a
couple of um
questions about the um or the first one
about the trees
i've read in the report um that there
was concerns raised by
officers and to a number of other people
about
trees lost to facilitate footpaths
that's uh
foot plural footpaths um
particularly the one through the south
the scheme has been amended in the
proposed footpath
through the south has been removed so is
there still
foot baths being created through trees
that aren't covered by the tpo
because i just want to be i just wanted
to clarify because the report does say
that only one sycamore is being removed
and that's covered by a tpo but are
there any trees being removed
that aren't covered by tpos um
that's the main question i think the
other question i have
is about the the um
the money being made available four
hundred thousand pound for affordable
housing
um i'm interested i'm interested to know
where where where actually does that go
who where does that money
who gets that money and how do they
provide the affordable housing
thank you thank you cal sagana uh
annabelle can you answer that please
yes if i can just come back on the first
point raised in relation to the trees
i'll just share
my screen which might be helpful
all right this is the uh tree protection
plan and this is the plan
as it was originally and submitted to us
so it had these here are the footpaths
that have been referred
these are the trees that are protected
by the tree preservation order so
in this location here that this was the
path
these trees aren't protected but they do
lie
in the application site and this is the
southern footpath that's referred to
that would have potentially caused an
impact on the trees
but this footpath has now been removed
from the scheme
so there will be no lost trees other
than that one sycamore as a result of
this application
thank you um come to ian
if you can touch on the other part of
council ghana's
requesting yes thank you chair um
so in terms of the the 400 000
contribution so that comes
so that's secured by a section 106
agreement and it comes into
the council um so it's held
until it's accessed by the council's
uh housing strategy team which also
responsible for the delivery of
affordable housing product
projects so obviously members will be
aware of a number of projects
in cliftonville a number of garage sites
in and around the district where
units of affordable housing are being
provided uh by the council
uh fundamentally the money will be used
to top up
um borrowing under potentially the um
the the various schemes that are used to
borrow money from central government to
provide affordable housing
um and will allow for the delivery
of um of additional units
within the district within the senate
district which is which is how it's
the provisors put um we looked at this
uh in terms of the contribution and and
the amount
and it has gone through both the head of
housing and planning blog posts but also
um ashley jackson as a strategic housing
manager
to ensure that the amount of money
that's provided would actually
be able to assist in providing five
additional units
elsewhere and on the basis of the the
amount provided it would provide
that amount by being able to be topped
up by the borrowing
to provide units elsewhere so we do
consider that it satisfies the
requirements
of providing an appropriate contribution
thank you chair
uh thank you and um councilman
monkey chair uh i also believe that the
potential
protection of the green wedge is vital
but
um in view of the fact that this land
has already been developed
i feel that the um to deny the creation
of
18 um homes
which which i feel have an attractive
design
um with uh also well planned
lane landscaping the retention of
all but one of the trees on the site a
contribution made to affordable housing
i i feel it would be unreasonable to go
against this application
thank you uh thank you councilman uh
council paul moore
yes thank you chair um i'm i'm at
loggerheads with this because um
as much as it's um a derelict building
and i'm all for rehabilitation of this
building and
the reusage of it and and it has been
shown that where they are extending is
already where buildings were
like the garages etc um i've got no
issues with that
my main concern is the same that uh
council robert baeff
mentioned which was it's the green wedge
area
and i would much rather see this being
returned but that's not going to happen
that's that's that's the gold standard
what i'd like that will never happen
um so i can see that this will happen at
some degree
something will happen there but i just
want reassurances
from the planning officer that the green
wedge is protected the trees are
protected
any trees that are removed uh we should
have
new trees mature trees reinstated on the
grounds elsewhere
so although we're moving it to
facilitate things we're putting it back
on that area
so that we don't lose um that greens
whatever when you look to that aerial
photograph
that is the green wedge uh if we start
cutting those trees down
all their all that their damage from the
building works
then we need to make sure they are
reinstated and replaced
um so i'm i'm at loggerheads with this
um i know it's going to happen
um so it needs to be managed and we need
to get the conditions and the
appropriate um
reservations put in place for this thank
you chair
uh i think councilman i think we've
heard from the plan here officer there
is only
one tree that would have to be moved
at this stage because of vehicles or
large vehicles
arriving on site so hopefully um
that that's got to be adhered to so um
uh councillor zesky yeah thank you chair
just a quick comment uh
looking at the application it seems to
me
it's quite sympathetic and using mainly
the footprint of
the existing building what would have
been
probably unacceptable would have been
more if they were to put 20 houses there
uh which would have been a totally
different matter uh therefore
i will be uh looking to approve this
thank you
thank you casewski um i cannot see any
other
uh speakers on this um so once again i'm
going to put this to yourself members uh
why check your question i i couldn't
type quick enough
oh god counselor um yes um it was
mentioned that we've got
uh money for affordable housing and i
don't think the up the question was
answered
what's gonna that's gonna be is that a
case that
um affordable housing is anything over
10 units and therefore some of the units
on the site
will be afforded to affordable housing
is that what we're talking about
annabelle can you um answer that
i can yester normally it would be the
case that a development of this size
and more than 10 units would have
on-site accommodate
affordable provision but given the
nature of the site it being a flatter
development a small number of units
being proposed
and the fact that it would be a small
amount of affordable housing that would
be required
there has not been a provider that
wishes to take
this development on
and is considered appropriate that the
um affordable housing is secured but via
a contribution to
offer schemes in the area that would use
that as
ian has previously outlined so it's not
an on-site provision in this instance it
would be
a contribution to off-site provision
uh thank you for that annabelle right i
can't see any other speakers here so
um i'm going to put that to you members
and recommendation of the officers
be adopted which is to defer and
delegate
uh would the vice chair please second
nature thank you uh council common cook
um again members you should know as i
say how this
works if you're for the state gains
and the stain um council coleman cook
four councilwoman four
councillor bayford four councillor curry
four counselor dennis paul
councillor ghana four counts of towning
four councillor keen four
councillor pat moore four
council paul moore four
councillor zesky poor council scott
for councillor right four
and myself i'm four as well so uh
uh unanimous that has uh been
motion has been carried uh thank you for
that members and thank you james for
letting me know okay um
i'm sorry we've had uh some members
waiting for quite some
time but we're moving on to it
item 4e which is a sportsman in
one two three sandwich road ramsgate
we come back to tsuki because i do know
you have two
statements one is for and the other
is an objection to this application
unless you had any preference i was
going to read the statement of objection
first
and the statement for second no worries
no leave it to you okay thank you this
is a statement of mr mrs taylor to ash
court cliffs and
kent we live adjacent to the proposed
development and object on the grounds of
the detrimental impact to our property
the planning officer has a judged that
we would be impacted by a sense of
enclosure and loss of sunlight
but considers this acceptable we do not
despite the reduced size of the cafe
apartment building
this is still very large development on
a very small site and impossible to
incorporate
the amount of separation distance
required to ameliorate the harm of this
development
we will be subjected to overshadowing
and loss of light
loss of outlook noise disturbance
loss of privacy and overlooking our
property was built with an integral
garage to the front
and designed to derive its main source
of light from the two
windows to the side of the property
these windows have an open aspect
towards the sea
giving a sense of light and spaciousness
the apartment building will be situated
directly in front of these windows
the applicant also intends to plant
trees on the boundary
reducing our light even further even
with
the reduced scale of this development
the close proximity and now
planting of trees on the boundary will
result in an overbearing and unduly
oppressive living environment
an increased sense of enclosure the
planning office
admits that this development has the
potential to cause noise and disturbance
but the former use would have had
similar levels of noise generation
we disagree the pub was a failing
business
and rarely used with cycle storage and
parking spaces to both the side and rear
of our property
we will be subjected to the constant
noise and disturbance of parking and
maneuvering of vehicles
residential access to the apartments and
access to the storage area
is at the rear of the property
subjecting us to noise and disturbance
by people entering and
exiting the residential premises and
storage area throughout the day and
night
the communal garden directly adjacent to
our property
will have a significant potential to
cause noise and disturb the peaceful
enjoyment of our property
this area could also be utilized as a
smoking area nearly feet away
from our property resulting in an
unpleasant environment
due to smoke drift the applicant intends
to plant trees along the boundary
the potential damage to our property by
the planting of trees causes great
concern
the planning offices states that there
will be at least one bedroom window
overlooking our property
but will have obscure glass what
conditions will be imposed to prevent
this being changed
how will conditions be policed it is
extremely concerning that kent police
are unable to recommend approval of this
application
and have significant concerns about the
potential for crime
the planning officer concedes the
opinion of the police but
states that no changes have been sought
as they would
result in harm to residential amenity
on this basis alone we would urge the
committee to refuse this application
this is a statement from hume planning
consultants
it says good evening chairman and
councillors i represent
hume planning consultancy in making this
representation to the committee on
behalf of the applicant
this site constitutes previously
developed land occupying a sustainable
location
within established settlement confines
it is proposed to redevelop the site to
provide two pairs of semi-detached
family dwellings
and three high-quality apartments above
a new bar cafe
given the contribution the development
makes to the local housing stocks with
the efficient use of
previously developed land together with
the new cafe bar facility
it is asserted that the development
complies with the principal policy
objectives
of the approved development plan this
application follows an earlier appeal
which although dismissed served to
establish a positive position on a
number of factors including the
sustainability of the site
land use compatibility with flood risk
considerations
accessibility and parking this decision
also provided a clear design mandate for
revisions to be made to the proposal
addressing the remaining issues in
question namely scale design and
relationship with the labeling buildings
through its iterative design review
process and collaborative discussions
with council officers
the proposal has been amended to
successfully address the areas
identified
principally through a significant
reduction in the scale and mass of the
apartment building
relative to neighboring buildings and
providing a suitable design response to
the appearance of the development within
the wider street scene
the amendments have reduced the scale of
the apartment building from that
considered
through the appeal by an equivalent of a
full floor to the front and
with the exception of the stairwell two
floors to the rear
the height of the building reflects the
ridge line of the existing and proposed
dwellings to both sides the degree of
reduction in the scale of the proposal
is clearly illustrated by the submitted
overlay plans
which compare the current proposal with
that considered through the previous
previous appeal
windows to the rear of the apartments
are now limited to two small
first floor bathroom windows which are
to be obscure glazed
the development has therefore responded
directly to the issues raised through
the appeal decision
in these terms the elevational treatment
of the proposed dwelling houses has also
been revised
from a series of four forward projecting
gables
to a more traditional transverse pitched
roof
officers are now satisfied that the
development is compatible with the
surrounding context and neighboring
properties
which is reflected in the recommendation
made in all cases
statutory consultees have raised no
objection and technical matters are
addressed
through condition the applicant has
provided a completed
unilateral undertaking securing a
contribution to the council's sam's
tariff it is understood that officers
will provide an update to members in
this regard
within the terms outlined above and
further to the officer's detailed
evaluation of the proposal
it is respectfully requested that member
support is given to the application
which represents a sustainable form of
development that accords with the
provisions of the mppf
and the adopted development plan
thank you very much uh suki for that um
i will ask now we have the two award
councillors um
i would ask that you don't say the same
items and i'm
certainly not being rude either of you
but
um i call upon councillor rogers to
speak first please
thank you chairman and members this
application was previously refused on
the grounds of overlooking
loss of light intrusion of privacy
amongst other reasons
and as quoted in the reasons for refusal
these buildings by virtue of its design
height mass and scale
would represent a visit visually
dominant obtrusive and incongruous form
of development
which would fail to respond to or
respect the low-density pattern of
development
and the predominantly two-story
characters of the surrounding
residential area
resulting in harm to the local
distinctiveness of the area
this is still a three-story building
having a detrimental effect on the
neighbours of ash court
it will still not be in keeping with the
street scene this proposed building
is also much closer to the road than
existing developments on sandwich road
causing a further change of street scene
cliffstone parish council has objected
regarding the height of the proposed
development
the close proximity to adjoining
properties inadequate parking
danger of flooding and the loss of light
and privacy of the residents of ash
court
whilst nobody objects to the site being
built on the general feeling
is that this is too high it's not in
keeping with surrounding properties
and it's an intrusion of privacy to the
neighbours so i'm asking for refusal of
this application
thank you uh thank you councillor rogers
council rather uh good evening chair
good evening members
um my colleague uh brendon rodgers has
gone
over many of the main uh facts uh but
another fact is the air the site is in a
valid um coast protection area uh we
will
know the appearance you know would be
detrimental to the area
um as said before the police do not
support the application
uh many local people don't support the
uh the application
due to the height the design of of on
the scale
of it and the actual design from
the previous applications that were
turned down hasn't really changed
as on that basis we i feel that this
application stood
should still be turned down thank you uh
thank you both of you
um i'll ask the planning officer to
outline the report and i believe that is
in
please thank you chair
i will just present my screen
and here we go
okay hopefully you can see the
presentation now
so the application is for the erection
of
four houses and a three-story building
comprising
a cafe a micro public ground floor and
three flats above
so the site is outlined in red the main
issues to consider are the principal
development the impact on the character
appearance of the
area living conditions of neighboring
properties
impact on highways and also
other material planning considerations
including the previous application
that went to appeal so the site is
within the village confines and does
represent
previously developed land um it does
provide
on the ground for a replacement
community facility for the public house
by providing a a cafe and micro pub
into the principle of development of the
site for both residential and commercial
government
is considered acceptable
uh this is an aerial image of the site
uh included this just to show um the the
isometric view to give you an idea of
what the building
that's on the site at the moment is like
in terms of
the the scale of it and also its
location but also to point out the
neighboring properties so 125 sandwich
road is here
and two excuse me two ash court
is here and we'll be looking at this
property in a bit more detail in a
little bit
so this is a view looking towards the
side of
number two ash court here and showing
the sportsman
here the site extends the full length of
this photo
so this is the the boundary of the site
and you can see
ash core as a cul-de-sac in the
background here and number two here
uh this is a view from folds lane just
looking to the plots
the plot is is i wouldn't say narrow but
you can see the extent of the the depth
of this part of the plot
and as you saw from the red line planet
it does vary as you move
east to west so this is
inside the site at the moment so you can
see at the moment hard surfacing across
this area
here as well as the the two-story
structure of
the sportsman pub uh just a detail a
more detailed view of the side elevation
of
ash court with the the first floor
window
um which has been cited by
in previous decisions to serve a
bathroom and a side kitchen window
here ground floor
so this is just a detailed photo of the
sportsman pub itself
this is a photo than the other side this
is a photo actually taken from
from google to show you um the
relationship at the moment with 125
sandwich road um so you can see that
the property here is set quite far back
from the site and
the sportsman you can see is set right
on the road at the moment
and then this is just a view from across
the road of the same sort of
relationship so you can see it's a sort
of angled boundary treatment
in this area here with then uh
garages uh before you actually end up
getting to habitable room windows
which is quite far into the plot there
of
of number 125.
uh this is a view just showing you
sandwich road so you can see again that
relationship of the sportsman at the
moment
set on the road itself
and then just the view from um the other
side of the road straight on
on the sportsman so i think it's
important just to
talk about the previous application um
the appeal decision has been provided
for members as a background paper within
the agenda
um so i'm just going to show you the
previous application so
the form of development is certainly
similar
to this current proposal that's in front
of members but it's not the same
in scale so it was previously refused
by the planning inspector after being
refused by uh
officers or more technical terms the
appeal was dismissed
um and that was in particular with
regards to the heightened massing
uh in particular with regards to
building b as it was referred to which
is the the building
um that serves the the mixed use
as well as the impact on the living
conditions of the neighboring property
of
number two and that related to impact on
windows and also to the conservatory of
that
property as well as overlooking from the
penthouse
flat in the the fourth sorry the third
floor of that property uh over that area
um in terms of the site plan for that
um you have uh the parking area
uh which was in the center of the
proposal uh
the four units to the left-hand side
here
uh and you can actually see the
footprint of the existing building in
red and then that proposal had a
building in a similar location to the
proposal that we'll look at
this was the design of the previous
proposal so you can see
at the top you can see the five units as
proposed
um in a sort of flatter development or
you know appearance of five units which
were three story
in height adjacent to 125 canterbury
road
um with then a four-story building
adjacent to number two uh ash
court um and closer to that vehicular
crossing
um so again that was dismissed uh at
appeal on the basis of of those those
reasons for refusal as mentioned
i just wanted to show this section and
this is the section that was
uh proposed from that previous
application
the section here shows number two ash
core
on the left-hand side and shows the
relationship
with um the the bulk of the property uh
you know the proposal as as it was
previously proposed so
as a as a four-story building so you can
see the relationship there and
and with the the side window which is a
kitchen window which looked over that
boundary fence in
in this sort of location here um so it
shows the the relationship that
that the inspector considered
unacceptable
uh so back to the proposal itself
um so what has been proposed in this
application is a similar sort of
uh form development as mentioned so you
have a parking area in the center
um as outlined by the um by the
applicant in the statement the inspector
did not raise any points of concern with
regards to the access or impact on
highway safety
and indeed officers in the highway
authority consider that as to be
acceptable following
some additional information that was
provided in terms of the level of
parking and the use
of victor access in this location here
so central parking area it does include
some cycle parking to the side of the
commercial building um in this area
here um so
what we're going to just look at here is
in just a bit more detail on the ground
floor plan so you can see that
the the four houses have um parking
directly off the street um with
space for parking internally but also a
space in front of
that parking area as well um in total
there are
there are 13 spaces within the central
area which effectively provides
two spaces for the
three flats in the upper floors of the
building
uh here and then the rest of the spaces
are available for the the cafe bar so
this is over provision in comparison to
the existing public house and the
parking that was available
for that and as mentioned the previous
parking provision that was made in the
previous application was considered to
be accepted by both officers
and also by the planning inspectorate
in terms of just going through the floor
plans when looking at the overall site
it's important to note the changing
uh mass of the corner build or sorry the
building that's
the three-story building here so you
lose
lose a bit of bulk when you move up to
the fort or the first floor
mention has been made of the windows to
be provided in this and we will look at
this in a bit more detail but just to
confirm that it's
two first floor windows serving
bathrooms
with the proposal to obscure glaze those
windows and then looking at the
second floor you can see that the mass
is reduced at a second floor level
uh either side of a central uh core
um and then you can see that there is
accommodation within the the
roof slope of the four houses with a
rear door window
so no proposed first as front door
windows
in the houses so just to look at the
design
in detail of the proposed houses so it's
proposed to be
pitched roof structures with balconies
at the front with a
a protruding uh timber clad element a
gray [ __ ]
gray slate roof uh with brick
work at first and ground
floor just to go through then the
elevations for these
properties you've got the southwest
elevation
this is particularly important because
this elevation is exposed
when traveling from west to east because
of the way that
uh the site has been the development has
been cited and the fact that those
dwellings on
sandwich road are set quite far back so
these are obscure glazed windows and
again the the timber paneling
uh cladding that's um found at the front
of the property
uh this is the elevation so this is the
internal elevation
facing the vehicle access and the
parking area
and this is the rear elevation so you
can see that the door window there
um serving some accommodation of roof
level
and then the section plan just showing
that relationship
so the this is the ground floor plan um
to pick up a point that's been raised
with regards to flooding
um the proposal uh does provide
additional information about
um mitigation for the potential for
flooding to occur um and there is a
condition
which is proposed which is condition
nine uh on the
uh application which would require that
there's no um sleeping combination
living correlation
uh for for um you know the purposes of
sleeping on on the effectively
uh below a certain level above ordinance
datum level and that is a requirement of
the
environment agency so this is why the
ground floor plan here
shows utility areas and storage
whereas the all of the living
accommodation is at first
floor level and above so the proposal
for these units is for three bed
properties so the bedroom is is in the
roof it serves that so
and then we've got the roof plan there
this is a visualization that's been
provided by the applicant
i think it's important just to note that
the different articulation in the the
feature that's provided
at the front of a first floor level
um i just wanted to touch on this side
elevation so this has been updated
as i mentioned so this is the elevation
that
would protrude past the unit um
adjacent on on sandwich road um so you
can see
if you look in this area of the plan
here you've got 125 here so set quite
far back
and then you've got the side elevation
that's exposed here
and then if we there we go there's a
photo
so in terms of the impact on that
neighboring property you can see that
actually that the
living accommodation is set quite far
away from the boundary
with the the the current uh sportsman
pub in the proposal
so it's not considered that the actual
sighting of a dwelling in this location
would result in
a sense of enclosure or indeed
overlooking from the relationship
between
the properties or causing an impact on
this property on sandwich road
so then let's just look at the third
sorry the three-story building here
so the proposal as mentioned has been
reduced by a story so previously this
was a three-story building it is a sorry
four-story building it's now a
three-story building
with uh ground floor as being a a
commercial unit and
two flats above oh sorry three flats
above in total two flats on the first
floor and one flat
are on the top floor
so this is the elevation that faces into
the vehicle access of the site
and then this is the elevation uh that
faces towards
uh folds uh folds lane um you can see
there's an
oriole projecting window that's here
which has an obscure glazed panel
facing towards ash core we'll have a
look at that in a minute
uh just to show that there wouldn't be
any overlooking resulting in the
proposal and
the only aspect that's clear glazed
would be viewing uh
towards the sea um you can also see a
proposed decorative
panel here but you can also see that
there's different articulation in terms
of the roof and
the scale of the building and then the
rear elevation again
just showing that this um this roof form
here when we look at the
perspective drawings and the section
plan is set in
at various points so set in in this area
here
and this area here and the only part of
of the the full three-story mass
is the central section here so these are
all set back
a roof level and this is set back at a
first floor level as well and
they've denoted that via the the shadow
but we obviously looked at that on the
floor plans
and this is just a section of the when
you're looking at the front of the
building just showing again
how the top floor has been sited down
to try and reduce the bulk of the
property
so just to go through the floor plans
here so you've got the ground floor plan
as proposed with the um uh the
the sort of the cafe bar
here you've then got the the first floor
plan in detail so as mentioned there's
the flat roof section where the bulk of
the the unit has been removed you've
then got these
first floor windows that serve bathroom
uh here serving the bedroom and the main
bathroom serving
uh this flat which is a two bedroom flat
and then there's a one bedroom flat here
and the obscure glazing on the rear
facing element of that window
and then the central core serving the
uh staircase and the lift and then the
flat
uh in the the highest point of the
building with no windows
serving that and no roof terraces as
well so that's removed from the previous
proposal that was refused by the council
uh and then this is just a roof plan
just showing that it's a it's a flat
roof structure
um and then this is the visualization
which shows uh this property so you can
see it's a slightly curved frontage
for the balconies here with different
articulation
of built form with balconies which as
we've seen from the
from the the photos are found in the
area on properties on
sandwich road all the way up so it's not
considered the presence of balconies
in this location would be out of keeping
with the character of the area
so this is the street scene just to give
you an idea of the scale of
the properties in question um as
shown here in red it shows the um
the previous application denoted so
you can see the the form of development
of these four houses has
changed so it's it's a pitched roof
style which matches uh the predominant
form of development in the area
and you can see the scale of the
building and how much that's been
reduced
for the three-story building or the
mixed-use
building that's been put forward um
so the proposal has reduced in scale
uh and obviously the the scale and
massing is one of them one of those key
points that was raised
by the inspector it is considered that
the you know the palette of materials
that's found all the way along
sandwich road has been reflected and
there are a variety of
different designs which do encompass
modern elements
it has been proposed that the the
three-story building the full
three-story building is a is has a flat
roof design obviously that has
been used to minimize the hype but it is
considered that we are in a
seafront location um that this does
um you know the site does support um
this type of
design and it doesn't in its in its now
new form
detract from the character of the area
in terms of
its scale or messing on this site
and it would sit comfortably on this
site in the view of
officers um in terms of the other key
element
that the previous application was
refused was the impact on
the neighboring property at number two
american corps
and obviously there is still a building
that would be present in this location
obviously which is to the south of it uh
and obviously
with the two side windows so the the
bathroom window at first floor is is
obviously a non-hampton
room window so that doesn't um result in
um a significant arm to that window but
the the concerns that
have been raised previously by officers
related to the
ground floor window and also the
the conservatory as well which was
raised by the inspector
um so this is a section which is showing
the the predominant mass
of the property at uh the proposal sorry
at
uh second floor level so the vast
majority of the second floor level is
is actually set away from the boundary
you can see what's been shown here in
terms of the previous
outline of the proposal um i think it's
worth knowing that the central stair
core would be slightly higher than
as shown here because this section goes
through the section which would have
basically be adjacent to the
conservatory
rather than the section that would be
adjacent to
the center of the property where the
kitchen window is
but what has been achieved here is the
proposal has been set
slightly away from um you know where the
existing
uh property was as a proposal was so
it's been set further away
and obviously that height overall has
come down by a full story
and in some parts comes down by even
more to be effectively just higher than
a two-story property would normally be
when it came
comes to the relationship with the
conservatory so
if i look at the second if we look at
the second floor plan here
you see the broad outline of the
property here which is the edge of the
property in purple here which is number
two
you can see the location of the
conservatory which was a key issue for
the inspector
is now set away from any three-story
element quite significantly
with only the central core being the
full three-story which has obviously
come down
from the four-story element affecting
the side kitchen window so therefore on
the basis of the proposal that's reduced
it
um the scale of the proposal it is
considered that the development
would not have a significantly adverse
impact on the living conditions
of that property to to warrant refuse of
the application
in officers view um so
overall just to summarize the proposal
is recommended to defer and delegate for
approval
uh this is subject to safeguarding
conditions uh but also the securing of a
contribution towards the strategic
access management
monitoring plan um in the gap between
um the publishing of the agenda and
um and and the actual committee meeting
we have confirmed that the unilateral
undertaking that has been submitted to
us
would be acceptable in securing the
contribution
however because um to avoid changing the
recommendation before members from
following the publishing of the agenda
um he's still down to defer and delegate
for approval
but we are you know we are happy that
the the the
um occupation in front of us would
secure that contribution
so taking account of um the previous
application and also
what the proposal would do to redevelop
a brownfield site
whilst mitigating the impact on
neighbours through the changes that have
been made
it is considered that the application is
uh should be recommended for
defending it for approval subject to
safeguarding conditions
thank you chad uh thank you for that ian
over to members i'm going to put first
of all uh recommend
the office of recommendation which
you've heard is to defer and delegate uh
with the vice chair police second
or second nature thank you look
right members i've got uh council robin
cass robin
did you push the wrong button again
i'll come back to council auburn
councillor garber
thank you thank you very much um yeah
there's one i mean i don't know i'm
not here
i'll come back to you steve
i just wanted to ask there's a couple of
concerns
okay raised by the neighbor
and also um councillor rattigan and
councillor
rogers before presentation and that's
about the
the concerns that are raised by the kent
police
um they can't the camp police can't
recommend approval for this
due to their significant concerns about
potential for crime
um i've just like wondered if um
comment on that
um if that's okay i'll come back on that
if that's all right
certainly yeah um so
um we've got we've received two comments
from the police
about the development um one of them
which is the first one
outlined um specific points about
um ensuring that designing our crime was
included within
um the layout um what what it raised is
uh it raised certain concerns about the
they said planned
open layout the rear of the site as it
lacked full natural surveillance
um and then no details of parameter of
perimeters of boundary treatment uh
currently recessed
and flat roofs areas which could be used
for climbing
and then it stated issues about visitor
parking being able to be
assessed and then about open car ports
and secure
areas for electric bikes as well as
lighting cctv
now um it's important to note that
obviously previously
the application did go to appeal and
obviously they looked at a very similar
form of development with the parking
areas that were shown
and the access and entrance to the
property that
the main three-story building was it was
four-story around the back
the officer report outlines that to get
surveillance
over that access to the properties
would require you to put windows in and
those windows would then
overlook the neighbor at number two ash
core
so that's why obviously it was
considered that it would result in
a harm to the living conditions of
neighboring property um
but in terms of the concerns of the
police about things like natural
surveillance and those issues
it's not considered that the development
inherently would create
crime uh to warrant a refusal on that
basis
um and indeed the fact that um
this has been looked at and these
comments you know have been put forward
before
but again the inspector has specifically
looked at
particular points of refusal with
regards to the impact on the neighboring
properties
it's not considered that there would be
actually the creation of crime by virtue
of the design of this proposal um
and indeed there are obviously secured
areas for
for storage of vehicles in terms of the
the for you know the four houses they've
obviously got their own
uh rear gardens etcetera and uh with
obviously
uh the you know the the areas inside the
property as well
so um we have taken into account that um
that you know they have raised other
issues about cyber security during
construction
those are transitory issues which would
not be something that
we would again want warrant refusal of
um but yeah just to address those
particular points with regards to the
police
uh thank you ann um come back to
councillor but now
push the right button that's wrong yeah
story chair
i don't know what happened there chair
anyway um
thank you um i think obviously the main
concern
for me was certainly the impact on the
neighborhood
property and um and
and i think obviously that was that was
what the planning inspector was
concerned about on
on the previous application uh from what
i can see each year
um i think those concerns that the
inspector raised have been addressed
um whilst i still have a slight concern
for the the neighbors but i think they
have been addressed
and i think um should we refuse this
chair i i
think we would lose on appeal so uh for
that reason i would
support this application thank you chair
uh thanks for that counselor
open uh councillor town yeah thank you
chair
um taking up uh what mike uh councillor
garner just talked about
the actual crime problem uh the
the sportsman pub was very much a family
pub
i i know the pub and uh the
the the the creation of uh
a cafe and a and a micro bar
as as you said ian uh is is going to
invite the possibility of crime
and looking at the neighboring areas
of that area there are a lot of elderly
people
there are a lot of lovely homes around
there and
you know they become subjected to a
potential
crime element um in addition to that
looking at the actual design of the
buildings
uh i think they're very much of a box
type building
you know and it detracts to me
it detracts from the environment of that
area
uh and and i and i i find it hard to
understand why
it can it could not be a development
that had some more promise and style
uh to that area uh so i i'm
i'm i've got mixed feelings about it
thank you uh thank you council town and
i think uh
all of us we we can't presume
um what's going to happen um you know
we've got to look at what's not
in front of us now but i totally
understand
uh i see a few hands raising now um
counselor
right hi
mr chairman um i've got mixed mixed
views about this development but having
visited somebody that lives along that
street and had to park my car
in the dark i must admit i would feel a
lot safer with that development there
okay fair enough okay thank you
counselor right
um before i yes
count uh i'm so gonna call you
counsellor again mr livingston but
ian thank you um just to come back
on the point um with regards to um
the the crime point i think um in terms
of the way that it would be quantified
about the the replacement facility
i think it's important to say that
obviously in consideration by say a
planning inspector indeed as the local
planning authority the fact that there
was a public house
present and this is obviously being
replaced by a facility that
in part is the same use class um
would not be able to to be evidenced as
the creation
of you know an increase of crime or
indeed noise and disturbance because i
think that is a point that has been
raised
um that you know obviously you know
members have
are aware that we've had situations in
the past where you know pubs have been
changed into other uses and
any concerns about noise and disturbance
um you know
it doesn't necessarily result in a
material change
to have a different type of facility
but it's effectively the same use class
in this instance so
there wouldn't be any evidential basis
that we could say that there was going
to be an increase in noise and
disturbance from the previous pub
to the proposed as as is put forward
thank you chair
yeah thank you for that and uh casserole
when you wish to come back
yeah thank you i just wanted to say that
um
as much as i like cedric i do totally
disagree with him about the uh
about the issues of the of of a small
uh of us of a small bar and a cafe that
would cause it
i mean there's only any traffic that
goes down sandwich road now there's only
you know
if anything it might be a bit of
footfall from cliffs in
the reason that the sportsman pub closed
down was because
because of the uh the diversion around
there
and and no traffic coming along to the
pub so
the likelihood of anybody pulling up
there when it calls aggro down in cliff
cliffs in his remote as far as i can see
i i wouldn't say it wouldn't happen but
you know
it's remote so i i don't see that as a
as as as an issue chair thank you
uh thank you for that council robin um
i'd like to answer that but
i i'm going to keep quiet um and uh
i can't see anybody else wish to speak
um so once again um i'm going to put
this motion which is defer and delegate
to yourselves could i have the vice
chair please second
or second nature thank you members
i've got to go through this once again
with you um
for against all are abstaining so i'll
call your name out
uh councillor common cook for
councillor auburn four council bayford
four councillor curry four
councillor dennis four
council ghana against
councillor towning okay
councillor keane four councillor pat
moore
four councillor paul moore
four councilman esky
four councillor scott
four councillor right
for and myself i'm for as well
um that is carried
thank you members um
for that i will get confirmation it is
thank you very much
uh that concludes public speaking
members but i
am for agenda item five um
i would just like to ask mr levinson to
introduce the report
uh thanks jeff so this is a planning
enforcement
update um that um i
i know that a number of members have
been been keen to get at planning
committee
um so the report that is in front of you
gives a bit of a general introduction
as well as an update with regards to
complaints and enforcement notices so
just to run
through a couple of different parts of
this report so
it includes information about the
enforcement process
so currently the way things are
designated in terms of enforcement
complaints is viral prioritization
system which is enshrined
in our enforcement protocol of high
priority and low priority
it then goes through the investigation
procedure so
establishing whether or not a planning
permission is required
then looks to seek to resolve matters
without formal action then decide
whether or not to take
formal action or not uh the report will
then go to what formal action might look
like so it gives some examples of
different types of enforcement notice or
different types of breaches
and it also covers other elements of the
planning of work that planning
enforcement carry out
in particular draw your attention to
matters of enforcing
section 106 agreements which obviously
members you see all the time in terms of
the heads of heads of terms that are in
these committee reports
and they can often involve quite
significant sums of money
and so is to ensure that obviously we
are enforcing those legal agreements to
ensure that those payments are received
and
and provided for community facilities
affordable housing highways etc um
so 3.01 and 2
go through um the complaints that were
received in 2019 and 2020
um so in 2019 there were 335 complaints
received
by the planning enforcement team with 78
of them
that were performed as high priority
and 330 in 2020
with 74 designated as high priority
uh the report provides a list and the
enforcement notice register for
2019 2020 which goes through
26 notices
that were served in that time
um and then the report talks about the
enforcement review
so um as the report mentions um this is
more of a matter for
uh tomorrow night at ovue and scrutiny
where i'll be giving a similar
presentation
uh with regards to a pro enforcement uh
review that's been requested um but
internally there is a review that's
that's just beginning uh which is a six
month process following an ombudsman
decision
which um wanted a bit of a review of our
our current processes so
we've got three stages to the review
that are going to be going on one is a
general review looking at the protocol
as mentioned
uh and also then looking at uh process
mapping
you know the the sort of complainant
journey almost to go through each stage
um it's then going to look at the use of
systems so it's a combination of how we
record complaints
uh how potentially whether or not we can
automate any systems to speed up the
processing of those complaints
as well as potentially looking at how
much the website could do in terms of
providing information but also
automatically filtering certain
information and providing updates
on um complaints and where what status
they are at uh and then the last stage
will be looking at whether or not we
need to define
uh sort of any further service standards
um and or whether
there's any um you know a review of of
resourcing and whether or not there's a
business case to be put forward
for increased resourcing um so that's a
just a quick counter through through the
report really
um thank you chair thank you ian um
i do note a lot of surprise here uh if
there are any questions because this
report is to be
noted um councillor alban there's a
surprise
yeah well it was only to thank uh
mr livingston for for bringing this to
two two members um
because it's always been the um
cinderella
part of planning for members and and
members don't normally get
in involved in uh planning enforcement
and um it's a very very important part
of the planning process and without that
um the decisions that we make at
planning
uh committee uh
may not always get built in accordance
with uh with what we've approved
and and the conditions that we uh that
we asked to be
put on are not are not always complied
with
and so you will see from the um the
2019-2020
list of enforcement that there are all
kinds of
different um actions that are taking
place including
uh non-compliance with conditions and i
know councillor ghana was uh
was very concerned about that um
so i think um i'm very grateful for you
uh
for miss olivia bringing this to us and
uh i i have no further comment to make
and thank you
chair oh oh i will wait one's asked
things here
um i know it's been a long journey to
get it here for about 18 months but i'm
pleased it's here in the end thank you
chair
thank you councilor alban and i agree
with
what you said it is a very important
part of the role we all play
uh councillor ghana thank you
yeah thanks so much i echo a lot of what
council auburn says
um it is obviously a very important
uh role within planning enforcement
because it's it's all very well lost
make us pass in a lot of conditions
um if they're not enforced then they're
not really worth the paper they're
written on a lot of the time
um so they the enforcement team worked
very hard
during the year and i thank them for
that um
and i can see they've been very very
busy um
covering 330 um
enforcement actions um i've got a couple
of questions
one um how big is the enforcement team
just as we all know how many
people are there in the enforcement team
and
how how do those 330
enforcement actions come to their notice
yeah abs absolutely so the enforcement
team consists of
um the planning enforcement officer
which is uh which is i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna name them
uh which is nikki burford and uh the
playing enforcement assistant which is
liam boyd
um and i manage them both sort of
directly so the enforcement team
consists of
two full-time staff members but
obviously they do
draw in work from the rest of the
planning applications team so planning
officers
do assist with certain elements of
planning enforcement work which includes
um supporting them at uh in appeals
against enforcement notices
providing reasons for for notice to be
served
uh and those sorts of things as well as
linked to the technical team and the
conditions officer and the various
different um different staff members and
in terms of how we get the complaints
uh predominantly they are
they are emailed to to planning
enforcement our family.gov.uk
um we do require a sort of written
complaint record
to be taken down we do still take
complaints over the phone
um but mainly it's it's via that
submission there is an ability through
the council's website to login
enforcement complaint as well
which then automates an email but we do
get we get enforcement complaints from
various sources
you know including obviously we you know
sometimes get through
stuff through the comms team through
social media if someone's raised
something
uh we actually get it from individual
planning officers we're now on site if
they see something
um obviously uh we also get them from
ward councillors
as well um which which actually come
into us as well but it is a
it's a reactive service so we do we
we are you know a complaint based
service fundamentally
um but we do obviously sometimes create
the
the the investigations as well as
officers
thank you and um i do see that
councilman moore is there but i will
come back to the council of ghana
no thank you thank you bob i realize
this is going to be um
covered in a little bit more detail
tomorrow night the overview and scrutiny
um committee so i don't want to get into
a
get into a big discussion about it
especially after
two hours plus planning committee
meeting um
but the key thing i wanted to understand
was about
the reactiveness of the the team how
it's a reactive team
rather than obviously because there's
only two of them
uh they're very difficult for them to be
proactive as in
going and checking checking that
developers especially on larger
sites are actually um following the
conditions
that have been passed by planning
officers and or by the planning
committee
but thank you and i'm sure i'll look
forward to further discussion tomorrow
evening
uh thank you council ghana um
tell us some more paul moore yes thank
you chair and thank you ian for letting
me know that i can now come to your door
and complain fervently to you when i
don't get an answer from nikki
or or her assistant um i think they do a
fantastic job
i think the team is woefully under
understaffed
with the number of retrospective
complaints they get and i think that's
something that might need to be
addressed in the future
but more importantly the problem i've
found when
reporting issues is it doesn't seem to
be a seamless and
seamless and transparent way of of
seeing how these things are progressing
so would there be a facility that we
have somewhere
on the tdc portal where counselors can
log in
and see how things are progressing and
at what stage they are because
obviously trying to get hold of nikki
and her colleagues sometimes when
they're out and about it's quite
difficult
we don't want to pass to you all the
time because you're busy anyway
but if there was a live document we
could see how things are progressing
would be really advantageous to us
because we can then
see that and if we see something that's
not happening then maybe we can then
contact you and say
oh by the way what's happening with this
one because i haven't seen anything
going ahead of it
and that would be a much easier way and
you wouldn't get pestered by
miserable counselors like me trying to
find out what's going on thank you
you said it counselor more um yeah
yeah um that's it's it's a very good
point and the the second stage of the
enforcement review was
was looking at um the use of systems
um the current system we use for our
planning database
um not to get too techies is a system
called uniform
which we update and has all the details
of our complaints
um that we've received in and that have
been logged on that system
we will be investigating the potential
for
um whether or not there's a similar type
of way that we can make things
complaints live as we do with planning
applications
not to provide any details obviously
that it's very
very important fundamental principle of
enforcement that complainants are
uh you know to be kept confidential but
to actually give an idea so that
not just counsellors but members of the
public
would be able to get an update about a
complaint that either they
or may have been raised in the local
area
about what status that he's at um
the the whole purpose of the review is
to work out and scope out whether or not
there is a possibility of doing that or
not
or if not how we can better communicate
with complainants and indeed reward
counsellors
to be able to provide an update um which
doesn't rely on an individual officer
typing an email so that is one of yeah
a particular point that we are looking
at uh thank you thank you and i think uh
please correct me if i'm wrong i believe
this
i i'm going to counsel robin but i know
time is moving on but
this may have been tried a number of
years ago
um i'm not saying it failed i think
obviously with staffing issues and so on
but i think a point has been taken here
and if
a very good point and if it can be
looked into um
chairman if i can come back uh just
purely
my own point obviously think you know
things have changed
so much from from one point of having a
uh from having a team of four officers
um
reduced to two yeah you know and then
having to
um try and uh
deal with the same issues across the
island
um and the same amount of com complaints
the complaints
averaged from between as you ian's just
said
three to four hundred sometimes more
than that you know and and
it's prioritization of of what you can
do
and of course is trying to have the time
in which to in which to
do everything in um i was always an
advocate of
of of having uh extra staff
because i think there's ways that it can
be done you could have a planning
condition enforcement
colleague uh you may have a full-time
planning uh
planning enforcement another full-time
planning enforcement officer
um however that's for ian and and and
officers to
decide the best way forward it's it's
not for councillors
to do that and also we we
we mustn't forget as councillors uh
where is the money coming from
because as we all know uh we haven't got
any
so it's a very difficult thing
for for ian to to try and get the
resources from out of his own budget
and they would have to come corporately
so if it comes corporately
then something's got to be cut somewhere
else so um
you know that that's something that's
got to be taken into into
in into account and um and i look
forward to the
uh to ian's report coming forward and
i'll be overviewing scrutiny tomorrow
night
as as i've been invited along for
another reason but uh thank you chair
for asking me
and i i i wish you all a fun good night
because
thank you thank you uh council robin for
advice there
and yes obviously uh council robin is
aware
in his previous life what he used to do
and hence the um
the advice members um
that report is to be noted um i know
we've
we've lost um had to leave george
council george zesky earlier he uh
goes along with the report so it is to
be noted
and that does bring
at shall we say eight o'clock
um this meeting to a close i thank ian
livingston and other officers for their
time
and members yourselves i know it's been
a long meeting just very quickly um
there's the possibility that there will
be two
planning meetings in march
one of them would be four weeks from
today the 17th
and more than likely the 31st
so please keep that in mind obviously
you'll be notified
and that's it um i won't keep you any
longer
um and thank you very much for your
attendance night and again
very good debate on the issues tonight
thank